hello everyone and welcome to another
absolutely incredible game this time
from The Challengers edition of this
this year's Tata still it is uh the
lowest rated player of the event Elaine
roybers uh she is 16 years old and she
takes on a very strong Dodge Grandmaster
Ervin Lami rated 2672. uh maybe it's uh
pronounced the Roy bars I don't know
Dutch names are very tricky for me so
I'm just gonna go with Ellen uh but yeah
the game itself is incredible uh you
guys will enjoy it let's dive into it
and see what happened here so Aileen
with the white pieces opens with E4 we
have Pawn to E5 Knight to F3 Knight the
C6 and she goes for the rui Lopez Bishop
to B5 we have a six Morpheus defense
Bishop to A4 and Knight to F6 we have
castles and Bishop to E7 so very very
standard stuff here uh Rook to E1 B5 are
going for the bishop Bishop to B3 and
pawn to D6 with C3 castles and now
upon the H3 all very standard moves and
now uh the player defense with Knight to
B8 preparing Pawn to C5 so very very
standard stuff over like 3 000 games in
top tier games reach this position D4
Knight B to D7 we have Knight B to D2
and pod Pawn to C5 both of them
obviously know what they are doing
Knight to F1 and now Rook the E8 we have
knighted the G3 now with some control
over the very nice squares here also
this Knight can be re-maneuvered to H2
then to G4 or maybe even the F1 then the
E3 all depending on how the game goes
Bishop to f8 now opening up the E file
for the rook and also the bishop will be
a nice Defender here Bishop backed the
C2 ending another Defender to the E4
Pawn uh and now uh usually you will see
C captures on D4 or E characters on D4
but Aaron plays Queen to C7 this move
has been played only once and the game
continued with Pawn to D5 material in
plays Bishop to E3 and it is now as of
move 15 to that we have a completely new
game so let's see what
uh Irvin had in mind he goes Bishop to
B7 and now she closes the position with
Pawn to D5 we have Pawn to C4 and now
Knight the H2 the Knight um uh getting
re-maneuvered here we have Ponte A5 and
now Knight to F5 controlling some very
nice squares here and it's just a very
annoying piece here uh if you want to
kick it away you'll have to play G6 but
that will weaken your king side so here
A4 and now Ponta A3 and what Ellen did
here uh she closes off the queen side
black can never break through here will
be for n she closed off the center so
now All That Remains is to attack that
King side she wants to play G for G5 and
then uh well just go after the black
king with black pieces uh pretty much
stuck here on the queen side so King the
h8 he knows what's coming and she does
go for it pawn to G4 uh Knight the C5
the Knight now is adding more pressure
to E4 also at some point you might have
to worry about Knight to D3 or Knight to
B3 but for now she you just defends thee
for pawn queen to F3 and now Knight back
to G8 you will have to remove it at some
point as G5 is coming so Pawn to G5 and
pawn to G6 we have knighted the G3
moving the Knight back and now Bishop to
E7 she defends on a G5 once again Pawn
to H4 and also she's preparing Pawn to
H5 we have rooked the f8 and now come
spawn to H5 and this is where the game
uh really becomes interesting and the
the real question is uh how does black
continue here of course black would very
much love to play F5 but Aline
completely stopped that by playing H5
but it's still not easy to see we can
even discuss it a little bit for example
if F5 f h characters on G6 now you're
threatening Queen to H5 but still on the
F4 and okay you invited the White Queen
here you're threatening Checkmate so
Bishop d8 you defend against Checkmate
but now Bishop captures and C5 and okay
F characters and G3 you're just just
gonna play dumb here Bishop capture sent
D6 you wanna remove the queen from the
defense of the H7 Pawn G captures an F2
with check King G2 now you're gonna take
the Rook here bring a knight into the
game also with check Rook captures and
now uh doesn't really matter what you
play now you are dead lost if Queen to
G7 you have to move your queen somewhere
just Bishop captures and again you
cannot capture because Checkmate on H7
so you have to capture here and now look
at this queen captures H captors and
down Knight G4 uh black is not down uh
too much material black is uh only down
by a pawn if you if you if you count the
pieces here but it's impossible to
defend everything here Rook to H1 is
coming and the black king will be
checkmated if you try to move the Knight
the give the G8 Square to the king uh
just Knight F6 now okay this is covered
this is covered there's no defense
against Rook to H1 so uh although very
interesting uh it's impossible to to
pull it off so here Bishop the C8
displayed now controlling some Knight
squares here but Elaine just plays Queen
to H1 now puts the queen on the same
file as the king queen to D7 now
preparing Queen to H3 to stop the attack
and now she goes for Pawn to F4 we have
Queen to H3 and now Queen to F3
uh we have e characters on F4 uh
interestingly here you should play
Knights the D3 I will just show why
Bishop captures spawn captures and now
after F captures an E5 you will capture
back and now after each characters you
will just play H captors on G6 in the
your position holds however in the game
e captures an F4 was played and now
comes Bishop to D4 with check we have F6
now comes Queen captures on F4 and it
seems like okay black might have
defended if now he can open up the
position should be very unpleasant for
the white king but now Knight to D7 and
here comes Rook to E3 very unpleasant
now threatening to just um well all
sorts of nasty discoveries become sorry
all sorts of nasty discoveries become
possible once this Knight moves and the
queen will be forced to capture on H5
and that's pretty much what happens in
the game Knight the E5 was played but
now Knight the F5 uh forcing the queen
to capture an H5 it's the only Square
for the black queen queen characters on
H5 but now Knight cat adapters on E7
Knight captures on E7 and now G captures
and F6 and there's just no good move
for for black here whatever you go you
do it's not going to be enough the pawn
is at some point coming to F7 so you
don't uh I have to worry about that and
the Knight will not be able to move due
to bishoping on D4 so here Irvin tried
G5 but now uh the position is uh well
once again completely winning for a lean
uh feel free to pause the video and try
to find the absolute best move for a
lean while I give you a couple of
seconds
uh for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations once again always
looking for cool ways to sacrifice your
queen and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it is Bishop captures
on E5 Queen captures and E5 is also a
nice Bishop captures 95 uh is a bit more
precise because now you really don't
leave black with any choice black must
capture the White Queen and uh hope to
survive G captures on F4 was played now
F captures and E7 opens up a discovery
and you cannot take the bishop because
uh then uh e characters and f8 comes
with Checkmate so King the G8 only move
he captures an f8 with check King
captures now Bishop captures and D6 with
check King to E8 and now Bishop captures
and F4 and now if you count the pieces
uh okay it's uh it's a rook for a rook
light score Bishop for a light Square
Bishop but Ellen also has a knight okay
we're gonna use different color a rook
bishop and the Knight for a queen plus
she has two connected uh Central pass
pawns and that's just Unstoppable so
here Rook the A7 is played of course you
want to try to bring the Rook to help
out with the defense King the H1
preparing Rook to G1 and here uh Erwin
could have uh made her life a bit more
difficult but he played Rook to G7 Rook
to F7 uh was a bit more precise but uh I
mean all right such things are
impossible to calculate with uh so many
so many uh cool options on the board but
let's say okay you attacked the bishop
Bishop G3 now you attack The Rook here
for example Rook 81 seems like white has
nothing to worry about but now comes H5
and now uh well slowly but surely black
will start to make progress white is
still better white it's only white that
can win this game but it would be easier
for black to to maybe try and defend
this position however in the game Rook
the G7 was played and Now Elaine just
plays a rook to G1 and that's pretty
much all there is for black uh black
traded on G1 captures captures with
Bishop to G4 uh but now just Pawn to E5
we have Bishop to F5 offering the trade
of Bishops but Ellen very happily trades
here captures captures Bishop to G3
getting the bishop to safety Queen to B1
check Knight to F1 and he was in this
position unmoved 46 that Ervin lemie
resigned in the game as there is nothing
more to be done here so an incredible
win by the lowest rated player in the
event Elaine Rovers uh taking down one
of the one of the strongest players in
the event he is not top seed I think
tabatavai is top seed but he's
definitely up there I think in in the
top three and someone who wrote on
Twitter that this is her first win
against such a strong player that she
never even defeated a 2500 player uh now
taking down a 26-72 grand master with a
beautiful queen sacrifice like that uh
if this doesn't kick-start your
tournament I I don't know what will but
truly truly an incredible game uh violin
so here you resign uh because there is
well really nothing to do those spawns
are now marching forward let's say you
play Queen captures on B to just E6 and
I've Queen captures an A3 uh you just
continue pushing D6 the bishop is
covering that if Queen to C5 it looks
very nice but there's really nothing for
black here D7 checking the eight Bishop
page for check like literally anything
wins here you bring a Queen you
Checkmate black and that's it uh so
after Knight to F1 uh Ervin resigned and
the spectacular victory for Ellen
Reuters in this uh round two of the Tata
still Challengers Edition 2023. uh so
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it I would like to thank
renderfile.net and Jimbo Robert Kiefer
doitran and ravishing reptiles YouTube
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing at the
coverage of the Tata still Challenger
and the Masters Edition until it
finishes so thank you all I will see you
soon uh and uh have an excellent rest of
your day